The correct answer is, everything after the opening
em tag is italicized. If your browser crashes you
should quit using Internet Explorer, and you know,
maybe this last answer is more truthful than joke,
because [LAUGH] there's definitely a world in which
browsers behave in a somewhat. Unpredictable manner, but I
think in this in this simple example, everything
after the em tag should be italicized. And let's
let's try it out in our browser just to be certain. Okay, text is where I left
it. No closing em tag, update. Cool, everything's still
italicized. If I were to you know, move this
em tag closing em tag here. And update, we
can see that HTML straightens up because just the
em is around this phrase. Enough of those simple
tags, let's learn something a little bit more complex.